hi guys so someone asked the question
what do I eat on a given day so that's
what I'm gonna talk about okay so I will
usually get up about 5:30 in the morning
and I will have coffee a very small cup
of coffee it's organic and I put cream
in there whole cream and it's grass-fed
organic a half a teaspoon of xylitol so
I will drink that and then I'll have
about four of my nutritional yeast
tablets okay I just feel good when I
when I take this I get up early I study
nutrition and during the time I might
have a Ticino which is a non
decaffeinated alternative coffee type a
drink or some more tea so my first meal
is at 1:30 and of course I love eggs
they're a pasture-raised
organic eggs I put sea salt and pepper
and they're fried in butter in addition
I'll do six slices of bacon or three
sausages or two grass-fed hot dogs okay
with the eggs so your bacon is not your
typical bacon it's from the farmers
market or I'll get it from us wellness
meats online okay the same thing with
the sausage same thing with the hotdogs
okay now I'll do four ounces of cheese
and sometimes I'll throw some olives in
there but I'm a little spoiled with
cheese okay so this is the type of
cheese that I like and this cheese is
produced from sheep on a mountaintop in
France okay and another cheese that I
like would be the Switzerland cheese raw
milk Cave aged okay and I'll probably
have like this much okay in my little
breakfast so if I have an avocado I will
also add that in there and that's pretty
much my meal and then right after the
meal I may consume about 4 tablespoons
of almond butter with celery or pecans
okay so sometimes they'll use the
walnuts with the ice cream but that's
going to be more for dinner not at 1:30
so I will add some my electrolyte powder
wheatgrass juice powder in a mason jar
shake it up and drink that down it seems
to give me some good energy through the
afternoon now about 5:30 is when I'll
eat dinner okay I'll have a huge salad
I'm talking like about 10 cups okay all
at once and I don't do spinach I do
other types of lettuce leaves and
cabbage cut bell pepper
I'll stick sometimes an avocado on there
maybe some other vegetables sometimes
pork rinds and seeds roasted seeds that
are salty with sea salt okay so then
I'll have my grass-fed beef or pork
sausage which is from the farmers market
again wild caught salmon as my protein
so the hard part is finding dressing
that I can eat that doesn't have the soy
oil or sugar so here's an example of one
that has buttermilk sunflower oil sea
salt onion garlic and zero sugars so
I'll use that here's another one with
just olive oil and the salt lick vinegar
which is great but again it's so hard to
find dressing without soy thus almac
with extra virgin olive oil this is a
good one no sugar and this is the one I
found recently at Whole Foods that has
extra virgin olive oil okay no sugar so
I like that
and sometimes for dinner I'll have the
summer sausage they're probably half of
this with cheese and you can get this
from the US wellness meats this is
amazing it's grass-fed grass-finished
and no nitrates no sugar then about
10:15 I'll take a sleep aid okay
so within 15 minutes I'm out so I'll
sleep for seven hours and start this
cycle over again okay so there you have
it that's an example of what I eat on a
given day hey you know what I just want
to say something only 30% of the people
that watching this video actually make
it this far and you did so I really
appreciate you thank you so much